[Musica]
la mia domanda è come rendere vitale la
tua organizzazione e perché questa
vitalità che è insita nella natura è
così importante
ho scelto questo tema perché quello che
più mi piace del mio lavoro la
facilitazione e aprire spazi nei quali
le persone possano fiorire
nella mia esperienza ho osservato due
cose che le persone sono collaborative
non sono egoiste e individualiste e che
quando apriamo spazi nei quali le
persone si confrontano entrano in
dialogo in interazione anche in modo
critico per arrivare poi a delle
soluzioni ha delle idee a delle
decisioni le persone sbocciano
fioriscono
pensate ai bambini che cosa fanno che
cosa facevamo i bambini o quando siamo
bambini
guardiamo osserviamo chiediamo siamo
curiosi vogliamo sperimentare sapere
tutto non abbiamo paura
poi quando cresciamo man mano che
cresciamo questa vitalità si spegne o
forse viene anche spenta arriviamo a
scuola e le il focus è sulle errore su
quello che manca su quello che non c'è
quello che ha sbagliato e prendiamo i
voti un 4 5 in 6
poi arriviamo nel mondo del lavoro
e qui abbiamo paura ad esporci a dire la
nostra perché non sappiamo quello che
gli altri pensano di noi non sappiamo le
conseguenze che possono nascere e quindi
ci ritiriamo in noi stessi e questo è un
problema
allora mi sono chiesto ma come
funzionano le organizzazioni ci sarà un
nesso tra questa vitalità e gli ambienti
e le organizzazioni sistemi nei quali
siamo
se dovessi paragonare le organizzazioni
ad un'architettura mi viene in mente una
forma molto alta e stretta fatta in
pietra quando i muri molto grossi molto
spessi le finestre sono piccole piccole
dall'esterno non entra la luce non
entrano le informazioni e poi ci sono
stanze piccole buy e isolate le persone
entrano raramente in comunicazione e le
informazioni non circolano
e poi ci sono scale in pietra e ci sono
scale anche nei processi decisionali
se un collaboratore ricevere
un'informazione dall'esterno da un
cliente
questa deve fare tutti i gradini del
processo decisionale fino al vertice
dove viene presa la decisione
e poi questa ritorna giù di nuovo per
tutti i gradini del processo decisionale
fino al collaboratore che la mette in
atto
come potete immaginare questo è un
grande dispendio di energie e di risorse
di tempo
intanto fuori il mondo cambia c'è un
mercato che ci chiede di essere snelli
agili veloci e quindi occorrono
decisioni snelle
allora mi sono chiesta ma se questo non
è un modello funzionale se non è il
modello ideale che cosa c'è che può
funzionare
e quindi mi sono messo a cercare a
capire a studiare a leggere finché mi
sono imbattuta in una community di
facilitatori che prima di trasmettere
alle organizzazioni dei modelli
organizzativi gli sperimentano su di
loro e quindi come siamo organizzati
siamo un bel numero di persone ma siamo
anche dei piccoli teams dei piccoli
gruppi e abbiamo dei format dei metodi
degli strumenti che ci servono per
confrontarci per prendere decisioni per
definire dei ruoli
e qui ha scoperto che è un modello
organizzativo che mette al centro le
persone con le loro potenzialità e la
loro vitalità e assomiglia a una
struttura fatta i materiali naturali per
esempio in legno con delle vetrate molto
grandi dalle quali entra la luce entrano
le informazioni e poi all'interno ci
sono degli spazi ampi non ci sono le
divisioni tra gli uffici e ci sono sedie
tavoli mobili ci sono lavagne mobili e
qui non è possibile che ci sia la paura
le persone collaborano o progettano
entrano continuamente in relazione ci
sono anche dei tavoli con dei lego per
fare dei prototipi per progettare per
provare e questo mi ricorda la vitalità
dei bambini questo approccio giocoso
divertente leggero
e qui mi chiedo ma esiste un
architettura interna delle relazioni dei
processi che favorisce
l'organizzazione vitale
dietro ogni cosa c'è oggi dovrebbe
essere uno scopo
penso di aver capito che cos'è uno scopo
a 13 anni quando ho conosciuto persone
che mi hanno fatto intravedere un
immagine di un mondo possibile
eravamo 5 mila giovani da tutta europa
in un palazzetto dello sport ci siamo
raccontati storie di cambiamento di come
ciascuno di noi cerca della propria
realtà della propria più quotidianità di
dare un contributo in virtù di valori
universali come rispetto le pari dignità
la trasparenza
e quindi io ho fatto mia questa immagine
di un mondo possibile
mi sento ogni giorno che c'è una forza
un'energia un motore che sento dentro
proprio perché ho quell'immagine di un
mondo possibile
e ogni giorno mi alzo e mi chiedo perché
mi alzo ogni mattina
e lo scopo è questo avere un'immagine di
un mondo possibile e alzarsi ogni
mattina chiedersi perché mi alzo
e negli anni ho potuto un po mettere a
fuoco il mio scopo che è quello appunto
di aprire spazi di vitalità nelle
organizzazioni
abbiamo dei principi
a supporto di questo scopo ci sono i
principi cosa sono i principi sono
ci servono per calare questo scopo nella
nostra quotidianità ci sono
organizzazioni che hanno il principio
del comando e del controllo che cosa
vuol dire che il collaboratore è come
una mano operativa che mette in pratica
quello che altri hanno deciso altrove e
quindi ci saranno dei meccanismi di
controllo per vedere se questa decisione
viene messa in atto
c'è poi un principio dell'autonomia e
responsabilità che vede il collaboratore
come un'antenna un sensore è un sensore
capta le informazioni che derivano dall
esterno da un cliente dal mondo esterno
e queste informazioni servono poi puoi
prendere le decisioni
e questo collaboratore ha un potere
decisionale ha un'autonomia decisionale
e proprio perché gli viene data questa
autonomia può esprimere anche la sua
vitalità e le sue potenzialità
e così funzionano anche i sistemi
viventi
se pensiamo agli alberi alle formiche
agli uccelli alle api non c'è qualcuno
che dice loro che cosa devono fare c'è
un meccanismo interno di autoregolazione
in base al quale ogni cosa sa che cosa
deve fare
ogni elemento sa come si deve muovere e
ogni parte è autonoma e nello stesso
tempo interconnessa con tutte le altre
e così funzionano anche le persone siamo
tutti connessi interconnessi e abbiamo
bisogno di questi momenti dentro le
nostre organizzazioni
e quindi si possono creare spazi di co
creazione di collaborazione dentro le
organizzazioni
ho potuto accompagnare un gruppo di 70
persone con un team di facilitatori per
due giorni e li la domanda era
che cosa rende attrattiva la nostra
azienda come possiamo fare perché i
nuovi talenti vengano nella della nostra
nella nostra azienda che cosa possiamo
fare e qual è il valore che noi offriamo
e come potete immaginare in questi due
giorni sono successe tante cose ci sono
state storie interviste
relazioni colloqui pensieri emozioni e
tanta energia che è entrata in circolo e
questo non è paragonabile a quello che
potrebbe succedere in un incontro a
tavolino quando ci che ci sediamo e
progettiamo un risultato
qui c'è un'energia potenti che è stata
messa in circolo le persone la portano
dentro e la trasmettono anche
all'esterno
a supporto di questi sistemi nei quali
si muovono le persone che vivono in base
a dei principi a degli scopi ci sono le
strutture che sono un insieme di
pratiche di metodi di strumenti che ci
servono nella quotidianità per esempio i
meeting tutti abbiamo l'esperienza dei
meeting sappiamo che possono essere
momenti molto noiosi nei quali parla una
persona dall'inizio alla fine e spesso
non sappiamo se siamo stati chiamati per
essere informati o per prendere delle
decisioni
che cosa possiamo fare per rendere i
meeting vitali
possiamo per esempio definire dei ruoli
come lost e un host che è non solo
quello che prepara un piatto di assaggi
ma è la figura che può arieggiare una
sala può renderla accogliente può
mettere un mazzo di fiori
in modo che le persone si sentano a loro
agio
però manda anche un invito con l'agenda
con un'intenzione di quel meeting e poi
ci può essere qualcuno che raccoglie
quello che ci siamo detti che raccoglie
le informazioni
non solo in senso cronologico ma anche
quello di cui abbiamo preso
consapevolezza
che poi ci può essere qualcuno che
guarda all energia del gruppo come
abbiamo lavorato come abbiamo comunicato
c'era un clima teso un clima disteso che
cosa ci può aiutare a collaborare meglio
e quindi questo dare responsabilità dare
autonomia alle persone è una possibilità
per le persone per esprimere le loro
potenzialità e la loro vitalità
e quindi siamo partiti dalla forza della
natura da questa vitalità della natura
l'abbiamo vista nel cavalli siamo
passati per i bambini che ci esprimono
la loro vitalità con la loro curiosità
abbiamo visto organizzazioni che per la
loro struttura sono piuttosto chiuse e
non la permettono altre che sono
piuttosto aperte e che la favoriscono
e poi ci siamo chiesti se esiste un
architettura delle relazioni dei
processi
che possa favorire l'organizzazione
vitale
e abbiamo visto che è importante appunto
avere uno scopo che ci dà una direzione
è importante avere dei principi che
calano a terra che mettono nella
quotidianità questa direzione verso la
quale vogliamo andare che sono utili e
degli spazi di collaborazione di co
creazione tra le persone in modo che si
possano connettere e arrivare a dei
risultati e che ci possono essere utili
le strutture che sono appunto queste
pratiche metodi strumenti come il
meeting che possiamo gestire in modo
vitale
dando per esempio dei ruoli
è l'ultima cosa che vorrei fare con voi
è quella di
pronunciare un invito esprimere un
invito e la domanda è
chiedetevi che cosa ti rende vitale
le idee che emergono mettile in pratica
saranno utili a te e alle persone che
collaborano con te li fai tu il primo
passo e non aspettare che siano gli
altri a farlo grazie
[Applauso]